DREA ALFONSO: Hey, everyone,
and welcome to Google Cloud Next
2017, coming to you
live from San Francisco.
I'm Drea Alphonso, a program
manager on our Google Education
Team, and host of
the "G Suite Show."
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And I'm Timothy
Jordan, a developer advocate
and host of "The Dev Show."
We're incredibly excited to
be here today and have you
along for the ride.
DREA ALFONSO: Cloud
Next is an event
that brings together
executives, customers, partners,
engineers to help build
the future of the cloud.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And there
are over 200 sessions--
DREA ALFONSO: Ooh,
a lot of sessions.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: --on Google
Cloud Platform, G Suite, Maps,
Devices, and more,
many of which will
be available on this
Livestream channel
over the next three days or on
Google Cloud's YouTube channel
later in the week.
DREA ALFONSO: And while
you're tuned in with us,
we'll be giving you a sneak
peek of what's going on at Next.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And
then we'll hand you over
to our keynote
speakers, who will
discuss Google Cloud
offerings today and a vision
for the future.
We'll also hear about how
our clients and partners are
embracing the cloud.
DREA ALFONSO: And while
Timothy and I are here
in San Francisco, we have
a huge global community
joining us live as well.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: In fact,
leading up to the event
we asked a few of
them to say hi.
Take a look.
(ALL): Hello from
Manila, Philippines!
Whoo!
(ALL): Hi!
(ALL): Hello from [INAUDIBLE].
(ALL): [INAUDIBLE]
(ALL): Hello from Hong Kong.
[INAUDIBLE]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And
those are just a few
of the many groups tuning
into the live stream today.
In fact, there are more
than 400 viewing parties
watching right now.
DREA ALFONSO: That's right.
And people all over the world
are gathering for Cloud Next.
We have Dubai, Taipei, Botswana,
and Warsaw, just to name a few.
Pretty much on every continent,
we've got you covered.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: What a cool
global experience right, Drea?
DREA ALFONSO: Totally, totally.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
OK, so what's next?
DREA ALFONSO: So
let's see, we've
said hello, they've said hello.
What else we got?
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Well, how about we
give everyone joining in
remotely an idea of what
it feels like to be on the
ground at Moscone Center in San
Francisco right now?
DREA ALFONSO: You know what?
I like that idea.
Let's check in with someone
here right now, actually.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Let's see.
There's Dave.
Dave, would you come
over here for a moment?
DAVE RENSIN: Hey, guys.
DREA ALFONSO: Hello.
DAVE RENSIN: How
is everyone doing?
DREA ALFONSO: Good.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: We're
having a great time so far.
How are you?
DAVE RENSIN: It's awesome.
It's crazy how big this is.
DREA ALFONSO: It is.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So for those
of you on the Livestream
that don't know Dave, could
you tell them who you are
and what you work on?
DAVE RENSIN: Oh sure.
My name's Dave Rensin.
I work on a thing
called Customer
Reliability Engineering.
It's a group of Google
SREs, the people who
keep our cloud up and reliable.
Actually going on call
and working with customers
to keep their applications
up and reliable.
It's kind of a new
thing in the industry.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Which is interesting,
because reliability has
got to be so key to cloud.
DAVE RENSIN: The
basic religion is
that reliability is the most
important feature of a cloud.
Because who cares about the
rest of it if can't count on it?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: What
are some of the most
exciting or interesting problems
that your team has encountered?
DAVE RENSIN: I
think I'll tell you
the thing that has been the
most awesome and surprising
in a good way, is
I thought when we
started this we'd get
a lot of resistance,
particularly from larger
companies about wanting
to make the sort of changes
you have to make to get
that kind of reliability.
Turns out they're
really hungry for it.
And so it's been actually
keeping up with demand.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Well, one last question
before we get going.
DREA ALFONSO: And what
are you most excited
about for the
future of the cloud
and what's happening at Next?
DAVE RENSIN: Well, I'll
tell you the sessions
I'm most excited about here
at Next are two of them.
12:30 we have an
SRE war stories.
And then tomorrow a roundtable
with the founding fathers
of SRE.
That's going to be awesome.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome, Dave.
Thanks so much for joining us.
DAVE RENSIN: Thank you both.
DREA ALFONSO: All right.
Thanks, Dave.
Have a great one.
All right, so great
chatting with Dave.
And there's so many cool
things going on today.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So many
people coming together
in collaboration
around Google Cloud.
DREA ALFONSO: And you know what?
I had a chance
earlier to meet up
with some of our
session speakers
and chat with them about
cool engineering topics that
will be covered today.
One of those things was
about the internet of things.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I love
the internet of things.
So let's get to that, but
when we get back, we'll find,
let's say, a cool
demo to check out.
DREA ALFONSO:
Sounds like a plan.
Yes.
Hey, everyone.
I'm here with Indranil,
who'll be leading
a few sessions on IoT at Next.
So he came by the studios to
give us a little sneak peek
of what we can expect.
So Indranil, thanks for
joining us here today.
As mentioned, you'll be doing
quite a few sessions on IoT
at Next.
Can you talk to us a little
bit more about what those are?
INDRANIL CHAKRABORTY: Sure,
we have two sessions on IoT
at Next, two breakout sessions.
One is called Developing IoT
Solution on Google Cloud.
And second is IoT and Cloud
for Industry Applications.
DREA ALFONSO: Got it.
And before we dive into that,
what do you do at Google?
INDRANIL CHAKRABORTY:
So I'm a product manager
with Google Cloud.
And my job really is to
do anything and everything
to build great products
which delights customer.
So I work with customers
to understand their needs.
I work with our engineering
team very closely,
UX Design Team,
Partnership Team.
So we're building features which
customers can really value.
DREA ALFONSO: And for
talking about IoT at Next,
why is that important?
Why is that important to
bring those types of sessions
to folks?
INDRANIL CHAKRABORTY: I think
IoT is at an inflection point.
We're seeing lot
of our customers
across manufacturing,
retail, even logistics
building really interesting
solution on Google Cloud.
So we think that we
really want to share
with a broader audience
what we think internally,
how we think about IoT
internally, and also share
the products we have on Cloud
as well as on the device
side, which developers
can use to build
really scalable applications.
DREA ALFONSO: And you mentioned
an interesting solution
with IoT.
Can you give us a
sneak peek in terms
of what are some of those
interesting solutions
that you're seeing
manufacturing companies develop?
INDRANIL CHAKRABORTY: Yes.
In fact, in one of the
sessions, one of our customer
is going to explain
and getting deeper
into a very interesting
solution they
have built with
manufacturing clients
where you can look across
all the different factories
and the manufacturing
processes, remotely monitor it,
get real-time insights
across all of your factories.
So we think there's
a lot of value there.
DREA ALFONSO: Awesome.
And so when we're talking
about the future of IoT,
what are you most excited about?
INDRANIL CHAKRABORTY:
Yeah, I'm really
excited the intersection of
IoT and machine learning.
If you think about what we have
done with our own data centers,
we've collected
vast amounts of data
from chillers, coolers,
and our HVAC system,
outside temperature, the
humidity and wind speed.
And we've collected
all this data
and we've built machine learning
models, which has effectively
improved, significantly
improved our power utilization
efficiency.
So I think there will be
a lot more applications
at this intersection.
And that's really interesting
over the next couple of years.
DREA ALFONSO: Well thanks
Indranil for joining us today.
And definitely looking forward
to checking out the session
online.
INDRANIL CHAKRABORTY:
Great, thank you.
DREA ALFONSO: Thanks.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: We're
here now with Terry.
Terry, could you tell the
Livestream how you are
and what you do?
TERRENCE RYAN: Hi,
my names Terry Ryan.
I'm a developer advocate
for Google Cloud platform.
And my job is to
basically go around
and talk to people
about Google Cloud
and try to encourage
developers to be
successful in our platform.
DREA ALFONSO: Cool.
So we're here in front
of a wall of pie.
But most importantly, we're
in front of the compute pi
cruncher.
Tell us what's going
on in front of us here.
TERRENCE RYAN: So one of the key
things about Google Clouds VMs
is that you can pick very
discrete amounts of processor
memory.
You don't have to choose between
8 and 16, if what you need
is 14 processors.
So this allows you to spin up a
custom VM to as many processors
as much memory as you want.
And we're going to
have it do a job which
is compute digits of pi.
So we can run this
whole process.
And you go from having no VM
to having a that's actually
done work catcalling
pi, 100 million digits
in usually around a minute.
You can do thing from nothing
to 100 million digits of pi.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I think that's
just incredible that Google
Cloud is computing 100
million digits of pi,
and you're spinning everything
up with just this one
button here.
TERRENCE RYAN: It's pretty cool.
Our web UI maybe a
little bit more clicks,
but we could get it down to
just this one button to do that.
It's pretty exciting.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
And actually that's
my favorite thing about
the Google Cloud Platform
is how easily you can
scale with your business.
TERRENCE RYAN: That is I think
one of the key differentiators.
And the fact that
you can make sure you
get as exactly as many resources
as you need without having
to go over, you save money.
That's good too.
DREA ALFONSO: So in
addition to the pi cruncher,
what are some other exciting
things that we should make sure
that we're checking out
here at the showcase?
TERRENCE RYAN: Well, I'm a big
fan of the whack-a-pod machine.
So whack-a-mole,
but you're killing
servers instead of moles.
We also have some great
things in machine learning.
The robotic candy
sorter and dispensers
are one of my favorites.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
We'll have to check that out.
Indeed we will.
Terry, thank you so
much for joining us.
TERRENCE RYAN:
Thanks for having me.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So we'd like
to talk to a couple more folks.
We know them as
Mark and Francesc.
You know them as the host
of the Google Cloud Podcast.
Here we are with Mark and
Francesc of the GCP podcast.
How you all doing?
MARK MANDEL: Doing great.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Doing great.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So why
don't we just start out
with a very simple and
straightforward question.
What is the podcast?
MARK MANDEL: So the podcast
is a weekly audio content
that Francesc and I put
together once a week.
And we do interviews with
program managers, engineers,
customers, a variety
of people across Google
and outside of Google to talk
about how they use Google
platform and the
lessons they've learned,
and the cool stuff that they
can tell people about it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
sounds pretty much right.
DREA ALFONSO: In
addition to what
you guys are doing
with the cloud podcast,
what else do you guys do here?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So we
are developer advocates.
So basically I'd say that
the developer advocate, what
they do is they kind of go
around the world talking
about Google technology.
And then if they hear
good or bad feedback,
they go back to the product
manager and [INAUDIBLE]
and they get the
feedback back basically.
MARK MANDEL: I've heard
professional sticker
distributor,
professional mingler.
DREA ALFONSO:
Stickers are popular.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We
carry t-shirts too.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
lots of t-shirts.
DREA ALFONSO: You
missed the t-shirt memo.
No, I'm joking.
I'm kidding.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Can I
still be at the party?
So I think developer advocates
do a little more too.
What would you say is your
motto for develop advocacy?
MARK MANDEL: So for me, I
would say quite literally
it is our job to
advocate for developers.
It was our job inside Google to
basically go out in the world,
interact with the
external developers who
use Google platform, and then
be able to be internally be
able to say, hey, we
represent the interests
and the experience of
those external developers
to our internal
product managers,
especially in engineering,
so that they have
that sort of conduit
of communication
to the outside developers.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'd
say in three words
like make developers happy.
MARK MANDEL: Love it.
DREA ALFONSO: And I am assuming
that the podcast is a great way
to reach people.
But how did you guys
come up with the idea
to do a Google Cloud podcast?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
I've been Google for way
longer than Mark.
DREA ALFONSO: How
long is way long?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I think
I could go for six years.
And I was not a developer
advocate before.
But I joined developer advocacy.
Ad And I always
liked podcasts, so I
was thinking about doing one.
And I was like, this
is way too much work.
ALFONSO: Can't do it by myself.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And Mark joined.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And he was
like, we should do a podcast.
And I was like,
that's a good idea.
[LAUGHTER]
So yeah, that's pretty much--
MARK MANDEL: That's
pretty much it.
Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
DREA ALFONSO:
Started with an idea.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: There you go.
And how many episodes so far?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: 61 today.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: 61.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: 61.
MARK MANDEL: So we passed
one year of content
a little while ago.
So it's been pretty good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yay party.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah
and the response
has been really, really positive
from listeners and everyone
involved.
So it's been really great.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Now y'all
are going to be on the ground
at Next doing something really
great for all the viewers out
there.
What is it?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah so the idea is
that we're going to be in the
middle of Club Next asking
questions to speakers
and attendees
and basically trying
to give everyone
a taste of what
the Cloud Next is
and then releasing that
as a bunch of episodes.
I don't know how
many of them but--
MARK MANDEL: It
should be interesting.
We did it last year.
It was really successful.
I think we're going to get
a repeat this year again.
Hopefully-- last year
we have some content
of people rapping that
we never released.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Maybe we could
do that again this year.
I still think that we--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Some Spotify
engineers rapping for us.
That was pretty cool.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
DREA ALFONSO: Oh, that
would be cool to hear.
I wanna hear that.
MARK MANDEL: We've been
doing that for a rainy day,
but if we--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: You're talking
like Cloud platform freestyle.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
Freestyle rap.
Absolutely.
Yeah, if we can get
content on that level
again I feel like that's
going to be great for everyone
outside of Next and
unfortunately couldn't
be able to attend to
be able to get really
a good taste of what happens.
DREA ALFONSO: And
for the folks that
are going to be tuning
in to the live stream
to see Cloud Next how
do they get in touch
or get the sessions you
guys will be hosting.
They're going to
be on the podcast?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
the sessions we're
going to be hosting
during the event they
will be all recorded.
So that's cool.
You can watch it later on.
And for our podcast they
will be available whenever
we have time to edit them.
At gcppodcast.com or
cloud.google.com/podcast.
DREA ALFONSO: And
then in addition to
being advocates and getting
out there and talking to folks,
do you guys also do
like developing the side
in your role in Google?
Or is it just more so
advocating about it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
we do development.
I mean, it's hard to
be a developer advocate
without being a developer.
DREA ALFONSO: That's true.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Nah, like there's
people that do it, right?
But like the empathy
of like, oh I
feel your pain, that
is very important.
So yeah we write a lot of code.
A lot mostly for fun.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Like demos and like
what did you do?
Like a paddle sucker?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah
my most recent thing
is like a paddle
multiplayer game.
I made Happy, Angry,
Surprised which
was Rock, Paper, Scissors but
with people's facial emotions.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah that was fun.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah so we
did a lot of silly stuff
with thousands of
servers in the Cloud.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's excellent.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Silly
highly scalable things.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
But it's OK.
As long as it can be played
by millions of people at once
it's fine.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
One more very
personal question--
coolest engineering
moment in all of history.
Go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You go.
MARK MANDEL: So I think
when the Mars Rover landed.
Like the stuff that
they had to do.
I have no idea how to get
like the jet propulsion
to happen in reverse so that
they could land properly
and they actually managed to do
it to make the Curiosity Rover
land.
Like, I watched that whole thing
with just absolute fascination.
I was completely and
utterly enthralled.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hmm.
That is hard to top.
Yeah I'm going to go
with the first phone call
because I think that
actually changed the world.
Yeah, like the first time
that someone got a phone
and was like, hello.
And someone on the
other side said hello.
That's pretty amazing.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right.
Before we get going, give
us all the addresses.
Where to get the podcast, where
you get in touch with y'all.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We do this
all the time on the podcast.
MARK MANDEL: We do.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
what is the website?
MARK MANDEL: gcppodcast.com
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
We have an email.
MARK MANDEL:
Hello@gcppodcast.com.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
We're on Twitter.
MARK MANDEL: @Gcppodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Google+.
MARK MANDEL: +Gcppodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And also on Reddit.
MARK MANDEL: /R/gcppodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
finally on Slack.
MARK MANDEL: Slack you can find
us on the hash podcast channel
at bit.ly/gcp-slack.
Less
FRANCESC CAMPOY: There you go.
DREA ALFONSO: You guys
have done that a few times.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, yeah.
DREA ALFONSO: Thanks,
Mark and Francesc.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Yeah, thank you both.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you
MARK MANDEL: Thank you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I love
hanging out with those guys.
The best part was hearing about
their favorite engineering
moments from all history.
DREA ALFONSO: Totally.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK, so we're
just a few minutes away
from the Keynote.
DREA ALFONSO: I think so.
Maybe it's time to let
everybody know what to expect?
Perhaps a sneak peek of
what will be covered?
DREA ALFONSO: You know what,
I think it's about that time.
So for the keynote
today we'll be
hearing from Diane
Greene, SVP of Google
Cloud on a recap of 2016 and
what's next for Google in 2017.
And Sundar Pichai
Google CEO on how
we're bringing all of Google
to Enterprise customers.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
And then Diane is
going to be back to explore how
our customers are using Google
Cloud products across
their companies
to innovate everywhere
from security to analytics
to machine learning.
We'll hear testimonials from
several Google Cloud customers
who will be on the
stage with Diane.
DREA ALFONSO: Oh.
Then next we'll do a deep
dive into machine learning
for the enterprise with Fei-Fei
Lee, Chief Scientist of Cloud
AI and machine learning.
And finally, we'll hear
some closing remarks
from Google's
chairman, Eric Schmidt.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK now I'm
really getting excited.
DREA ALFONSO: Me too.
And it looks like folks are
just starting to get seated.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Well, before we
hand you over to the big stage,
I'd like to let you know
that Drea and I will be back
tomorrow before the keynote
with day one in review
and more exclusive interviews
that you won't want to miss.
We'd love to hear your thoughts
on the future of the Cloud
or answer any questions
for you while we're here
with all the experts.
You can find us on Twitter.
Our handles are on your screen.
Enjoy the show.
And we'll see you tomorrow.
DREA ALFONSO: See ya.